[Music]
happy beeps here buddy come on
Oh
[Music]
physically I never really had to push
myself that hard
and stamina wise you're like oh my god
it's like a psychological thing of
knowing that you can do it more and more
and more Daisy is training for a moment
where she is on the islands and she has
a moment to herself and she's practicing
with the staff
and then she realizes what am I wasting
my time practicing with the staff I have
Luke Skywalker's the lightsaber in my
satchel it's just working out the moves
for that action
[Music]
I was a planning teacher her the whole
routine in three days but she
surprisingly then everything in an hour
she's a very quick learner
[Music]
this is the hardest physical thing I've
done yet
the suit can be very restrictive just to
move in just to walk in you do the move
and you think gosh is it lunchtime yet
finem phasma end up face-to-face which
results in a major fight one thing I do
want to do is do the whole fight by
myself there's really good scenes to
shoot very tiring her
what was cool was learning different
types of fighting
was intense and fun a really hard
training yesterday was great and then
today we started and honestly uh I was
watching out him and he gives it so full
out every single time I mean it was kind
of like oh my god I can do that I can do
that
it's just rigorous in a great way and
these stunt guys are very disciplined so
you can't half-ass it
the spawn tema absolutely amazing they
let my boys and girls
hey everybody happy Star Wars month
there's so much stuff that we have to
get through so I cut this down just a
little bit because there's more behind
the scenes with the director Rian
Johnson talking about some of the new
characters like Rose Tico or Benicio Del
Toro's DJ character on canto byte but
there's a couple key scenes that they're
rehearsing here with their lightsaber
battles and I know a lot of people are
wondering what types of techniques that
they're going to develop for that though
because up to this point where Luke
Skywalker's like the Jedi Order needs to
end there were some classic styles that
you would train in with a lightsaber so
you would say certain people were using
form 4 or form 1 or form 2 or something
like that but I think part of the idea
from this behind the scenes that you get
is that she's training with that staff
like maybe Luke Skywalker's like slowly
ramping her up or doesn't want anything
to do with it and then she sees the
lightsaber sitting in the backpack and
it's just like screw this I'm going to
use Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber but
because she's never actually trained
with the real lightsaber before she's
just hacking away at the air but if you
are finding me for the first time like I
said this is gonna be the month of Star
Wars there's gonna be so much different
stuff going on even beyond the last Jedi
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and I will be doing IMAX
ticket giveaways in the videos I usually
name new winners at the end of these but
at the beginning of that footage you
actually see some new x-wing shots with
Poe Dameron and bb-8 it looks like
they're attacking the base that finn is
going to be fighting on because there
are a couple big first order locations
that we know about so there's one the
supremacy which is Snoke ship that's
where you see a lot of those Rey scenes
where it looks like she's being tested
by Snoke then there's a lot of separate
scenes with Finn on his mission to
infiltrate the first order as he
interacts with phasma and all these
other places here but it's a little hard
to tell just from these interior shots
whether they're also on the Supremacy
separate from what Rey is doing because
it does sound like they come back
together on crate which is probably from
the later battles in the film so like
all this salt planet stuff that you see
like when the first-order troopers are
walking into this area here when you see
the Falcon flying through all these
tunnels these big space battles here
that all looks like it's happening
towards the end of the film once the
characters have come back together
because you do see Rey get a couple
costume changes like she has the early
outfits that she's wearing here when
she's still on talked to but then later
when you see her on this
premise see inside snoke's throne-room
she's wearing her gray Jedi robes so you
can chart the time line of the movie
just a little bit based on the costume
changes people get because she's in
those grey Jedi robes when she's on
crate standing next to Finn these fights
that she's training for when she's
fighting multiple people at the same
time look like they might be happening
on the supremacy because this person
here actually either looks like he's
wielding a baton or another lightsaber
like this is her training to fight kylo
Ren inside this throne room here like it
might be a twist on the Vader fight at
the end of Empire and Return of the Jedi
but it does look like one of these
people that she's fighting is one of the
Praetorian guards but the other cool
thing about this is obviously all of the
kylo ren fights I mean it's cool to see
phasma training she's just a total
badass like Brienne of Tarth in space is
gonna kick a lot of butt before fin
maybe narrowly escapes I don't think
there's any way that Finn can beat her
in one-on-one combat so speaking of
which kylo Ren's lightsaber style I love
the way that he wields such a long blade
like you see him just spinning around
like there's so much force behind his
strikes and it's almost like he's
fighting with a giant two-handed
broadsword but he's trying to wield it
at times with one hand so he just has to
hold it while he's throwing other people
using the Force
the interesting thing about this though
is that it doesn't tell us whether or
not kylo Ren is just in a training
session with the Praetorian guards or
with the Knights of rent or if he's gone
rogue and he is legit fighting them
there's this real push-pull thing going
on with kylo Ren and snoke's narrative
where Snoke is really upset and
dissatisfied with him and it sounds like
kylo Ren is also growing dissatisfied
too so he might wind up going rogue at
some point during the trilogy but let me
know in the comments what do you think
is actually happening in these
lightsaber fights that the actors are
training for it what will happen is is
there is some more behind the scenes
with the director talking about the
other characters that I might post later
but I'm expecting some more footage to
be dropping really soon so there'll be
all kinds of Star Wars stuff happening
in the next week but leave all your
requests for bonus videos in the
comments below there'll be some more
Marvel and DC stuff posting really soon
there's a new round of that IMAX sticky
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment
about Star Wars stuff on this video
congratulations to the winner from last
week Mysterio gamer please private
message me so
can get your contact details you can
click here for more new Star Wars the
last Jedi and you can click here to
rewatch that infinity war trailer a
billion more times thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome i'll see
you guys tonight